Ryan Murphy you son of a [ __ ] you son
of a [ __ ] yes another season of
American Horror Story has come to an end
and I'll be perfectly honest I really
enjoyed it if you liked the campaign s
pardon the pun and if you're also like
me who grew up watching cheesy 80
slasher movies this season was such a
fun homage to those films I would even
put this season in my top 3 yes I know
that statement will automatically get me
some dislikes that being said the ending
although good was not great leaving a
lot to be desired both plot and
character wise so in this video I'm
gonna go over how American Horror Story
1984 should have ended now before we get
into this new ending we have to go over
an important ground rule episode one to
eight will remain unchanged this isn't
because I think they're perfect that's
not the case at all it's just that if I
started cherry-picking things here and
there to change this video would get
super complicated and I want to avoid
that now that we've got that out of the
way we need to focus on those aspects of
the finale that I think need to be
changed and I'll focus more on broad
criticisms than nitpicking minor things
like oh I wish Xavier had more air time
I see you Cody fern fans out there
my three main criticisms are as follows
one the curse of camp redwood was never
fully explored or resolved to some of
the most important character arcs namely
Brooke and Ricky were deeply
unsatisfying and finally the lack of
tie-ins to other AHS seasons the curse
of camp redwood is an enigma to me with
rules that seem to switch episode to
episode in order for certain plot points
to be hit by the writers like how long
does it take for a body to resurrect
that kind of changes throughout the
season how can Lavinia seemingly
teleport
where did jingles go at the end of
episode 8 for now let's focus on what we
do know about this curse and build our
ending around that one it started in
1948 with the death of bobbie richter
and her mother's subsequent murder spree
resulting in benjamin killing his own
mother this is why we don't have any
super old-timey ghosts which would hint
that the curse goes way before 40
after the massacre and death of Lavinia
anyone killed within the camp redwood
property is resurrected as a ghost for
all eternity it's essentially their own
limbo in the current ending there's no
real resolution to this curse when I
think there should be if Lavinia gets
Bobby back and patches things up with
Ben the curse theoretically should be
lifted but the ending we got the campers
were still stuck at redwood we'll get to
how I'll change this in a bit character
arcs were also a big problem for me
mainly those of Brooke and Ricky Brooke
starts off the season as our main
protagonist yet the final episode has
her hiding away marrying a dermatologist
and her only real purpose in the episode
is to exposition dump everything that
happened to her since 1989
Ricky although he doesn't have quite an
arc since his character is pretty static
throughout the season didn't get an
ending worthy of his evil character by
that I mean he could have gotten it a
lot worse now I don't mean physically
since his death was quite brutal but
emotionally an emotional betrayal of
sorts by someone he admires more than
anyone else we'll get to that too
and finally the ending missed some great
opportunities to tie in previous HS
seasons HS is known for connecting tons
of characters from different seasons to
one another and I think they could have
exploited this much more particularly
Ricky's relationship to Satan tying in
to apocalypse okay you've heard my
critiques now I'm gonna show you how I
think this season should have ended keep
in mind my ending is Patchett insane but
hey so was the season it likely has its
own problems I wrote this in a day and
it likely wouldn't happen due to well
you'll just have to keep watching let's
get into it we start just like the
original ending a grown up Bobby Richter
has arrived at Camp redwood in 2019
searching for answers about his father
whereas the original has him meet
Montana and Trevor in my version he
meets jingles his dad one of the things
I didn't like about the original was
that Bobby and jingles hug once and
that's about it
in my way it allows them to connect a
bit more before they big finale so that
when things finally get resolved we feel
more attached to them and it's more
emotional less forced well jingles will
go on to say that he and the other
ghosts are stuck for it
Trinity at Camp redwood their souls will
never be at rest the curse was supposed
to be lifted when Lavinia was reunited
with Bobby but some evil force is
preventing the ghosts aka the other
campers and counselors from moving on
it's here the other ghosts reveal
themselves to Bobby as we flash back to
1989 to hear the story of what happened
at the festival Trevor will block the
road preventing the festival goers from
getting in but it's here none other than
Billy Idol arrives in his tour bus
played of course by Evan Peters but
someone else should he not be available
he's flown all the way from the UK and
is pissed
what do you mean the festival's canceled
he gave up a meeting with the Queen to
be here will he still be getting paid he
storms past Trevor on to the camp
redwood grounds in search of Margaret
demanding answers I like this version
because the original built up Billy Idol
for almost three episodes and there was
no payoff Billy can also be used
plot-wise to manipulate Ricky since we
know how much he loves him Montana will
exploit this by telling Ricky she's
arranged a private meeting with him away
from all the other less devoted fans and
this could take place in Lavinia Shack
where the other ghosts wait for him
trapping him in there similar to the
original we flash forward back to
present day where jingles brings his son
to see Ricky who they have tied up and
confined in his own satanic cell for the
past 30 years this scene could be fun
since you'll have Ricky taunting Bobby
saying he'll get his revenge and saying
how he enjoyed carving up his mother but
the real purpose of this scene is to
highlight how whatever satanic power is
trapped within Ricky is preventing the
curse from being lifted the ghosts have
tried everything but Ricky keeps coming
back to life with his satanic spirit
trapped within him if they can somehow
remove this demonic force from his body
maybe they can break the curse
in the mean time they've done the only
thing they can keep him confined so he
can't escape red wood
Bobby is now determined he says he'll
find a way to lift the curse and save
the other ghosts after all it was his
father and the other ghosts who have
been protecting him in the world all
these years from the evil that is Ricky
it's the least
can do jingles tells Bobby to start his
quest with Donna chambers at the red
Meadows Asylum she may have some answers
Bobby visits Donna at the asylum similar
to how he did in the original here we'll
have Donna recount how Brook and her got
the revenge and killed Margaret but my
version has an injured Brook being taken
to the camps edge by Ray only for her to
be saved by none other than Billy Idol
whose tour bus is still there as we
flash-forward Bobby says he thought
Brooke didn't survive he searched
everywhere for a Brooke Thompson but
couldn't find one that's because she's
no longer Brooke Thompson are you ready
for this she's Brooke Idol yes the girl
who started as a virgin with the
squeaky-clean lifestyle has come full
circle marrying one of the most badass
singers in rock and roll
a marriage that would have had to be
kept secret since Brooke is still
considered to be dead from death row
Bobby goes to the gates outside Billy's
mansion and is turned away by the guard
who thinks he's a crazy fan shouting
things about ghosts and camp redwood
kind of like how he was turned away at
the asylum but Brooke will overhear this
and bring him inside where Bobby will
plead with her to go back they need to
save the others and stop Ricky for good
the curse of Redwood needs to be lifted
and he doesn't know who to turn to
back at redwood a few days later Chet
and birdy are on the night shift looking
after Ricky just like the original when
they are viciously murdered by none
other than Billy Idol but as we'll find
out spoiler alert this is all part of
the plan it's not a big deal to kill
Chet and birdy since they'll just
resurrect again Ricky is astonished to
see his true hero helping him out of his
confinement Billy saying that Satan
talked to him and ordered him to set
Ricky free that Satan isn't done with
him Billy tells them a boat is waiting
for them at the dock and that they'll
finally be free once they get off the
property
as they get down to the dock Ricky
remarks where's the boat but it's all a
trap revealing cordelia at the other end
of the dock yes the cordelia good from
coven and apocalypse if there's anyone
who can deal with satanic beings it's
her and you know I had to bring our girl
Paulson back as we'll find out Billy is
actually a warlock who attended
Hawthorne hence how he would know
Cordelia and we could also tie this into
his success as
a rockstar Cordelia will cast a spell
lifting Ricki into the air as the
demonic spirit escapes from his throat
and mouth the other ghost from the
season emerge from the forest watching
as these events unfold including both
Bobby jingles Lavinia and Bobby jr. all
side by side with a final blow the
demonic entity is destroyed
casting the entire lake and forest in
bright white light
Ricky's body collapsing on the edge of
the dock the curse has been lifted and
Ricky is now mortal Billy takes Ricky's
curved knife ready to end him for good
it's the biggest betrayal for Ricky his
hero being the one to kill him when
Brooke swerves in and guts him in the
stomach after all it was Ricky who first
tried to kill her in episode 1 with
blood coming out from his mouth his face
of betrayal turns to an evil smirk as he
recites Billy's lyrics from his song
rebel yell saying more more MORE as
Montana and the other ghost stabbed him
mercilessly we get a goodbye between
jingles and Bobby before a mysterious
force slowly pulls the ghost towards the
center of the lake Cordelia Bobby Brooke
and Billy watch as the ghosts disappear
above the lake their souls finally put
to rest and the curse of red would
finally lifted I would have loved to
have months working on a better ending
than this one but hey with a half day
and not having to worry about whether
Evan Peters or Sarah paulsen could come
back I thought this would be a fun
exercise for all of us AHS fans out
there if you enjoyed it I would love it
if you gave it a like and made a comment
and make sure to subscribe since I have
tons of other videos coming up before
- HS season you can also follow me on
twitter at things story YT until next
time remember daddy loves you very much